the 2023 Oscars were filled with plenty
of highs and lows including a host who
didn't exactly please everyone for the
95th Academy Awards Jimmy Kimmel was
once again tapped as the MC having
previously hosted the ceremony in 2017
and 2018. but the third time wasn't
exactly the charm at least According to
some viewers following Kimmel's opening
monologue which highlighted the knights
nominated films social media quickly
began to blow up with thoughts about his
jokes multiple users thought his
delivery timing was off and that he
maybe needed to slow down a bit one
person even referenced a certain
fictional conductor by tweeting we need
Lydia Tarr pushing Jimmy Kimmel off the
stage at the Oscars just for fun while
Kimmel's jokes weren't necessarily that
bad it's always fun to see viewers come
up with clever references to the
nominated films Kimmel actually praised
tar but some observers found his
thoughts on the Kate Blanchett starring
vehicle to be condescending as one
person tweeted Jimmy Kimmel is making
jokes about tar as if the entire scene
he he just marked isn't a biting satire
on everything happening tonight others
weren't exactly pleased when Kimmel went
negative while the Oscars have never
shied away from calling out some of
Hollywood's Duds and misfires some
viewers thought that his jab at the
Damien chazelle directed Babylon went
way too far as one person tweeted in all
caps get Jimmy Kimmel off the stage I
draw the line at Babylon slander another
fan of the oscar-nominated Epic agreed
by tweeting I'm gonna start the Jimmy
Kimmel hate train for the Babylon discs
some viewers even went so far as to
declare that Kimmel's monologue was a
total bomb as one of them bluntly
tweeted how many more years must we be
subjected to Jimmy Kimmel Kimmel was
also called out by Indian cinephiles for
referring to the Telugu language film
rrr as a Bollywood production when
tollywood would have been more accurate
do you know
Desi Notch while Kimmel received his
fair share of flack on the internet some
other viewers were actually pleased with
how the host was mostly sharing the
magic of Cinema he was praised for
eliciting gasps and nervous laughter
from the crowd at least one Twitter user
went so far as to declare the monologue
one of the best in recent memory and as
another noted Jimmy Kimmel's monologue
is going well good job on the no women
director nomination joke
Kimmel was also positively compared to
past Oscar hosts like Bob Hope and
Johnny Carson and he enjoyed a call out
to a spectacle from across the pond as
someone tweeted his parachute in was a
ripoff of Queen and bond at the London
Olympics but a better version though
Kimmel's third outing as Oscar's host
wasn't able to please everyone at least
he was able to find some fans on social
media But ultimately in many ways it
doesn't really matter who the host is
after all viewers across the world are
mainly tuning in to celebrate Cinema and
regarding that requirement Kimmel did a
decent job his opening monologue
highlighted some of the year's most
inventive films and reminded audiences
just how important seeing movies on the
big screen is Kimmel even went ahead and
casually called out James Cameron and
Tom Cruise for not showing up to the
ceremony even though they're two of the
theatrical experiences most Ardent
supporters some Twitter users argue that
Kimmel deserves praise for not shying
away from pointing out how no women were
nominated for best director this year
and they also found it hard not to
appreciate him for dragging Warner
Brothers Discovery over their
cancellation of the Batgirl movie
starring Leslie Grace Kimmel wasn't
perfect but he also doesn't deserve a
toxic spew of hatred then again the
jokes pitting him against Lydia Tarr
were pretty hilarious
who may I ask gets to decide that
this year more than ever it's Crystal
Clear that the Oscars wanted to
celebrate the movies and Jimmy Kimmel
clearly understood the assignment
[Music]